now over the last four years or so
hundreds of young British men and women
have gone to Syria and Iraq to fight for
an organization dedicated to the
destruction of their own country some
took to Islamic states calls so
enthusiastically that they became the
faces of the extremists call to arms
carrying out the most brutal acts for
all the world to see others became
soldiers wives killers and enforces at
the heart of Islamic state
self-proclaimed caliphate at least 130
have died fighting for is but many still
remain and with the fall of Raqqa the
groups de facto capital in Syria some
are now seeking to return to the country
they once and perhaps still regard as
their enemy well over the next half an
hour we'll discuss how governments and
policy makers should now deal with a
threat of returning British foreign
fighters with a panel of experts and
specialists and decide if there can be
justice for jihadis well joining me in
the studio are chip Chapman former head
of counterterrorism and UK operations in
the ministry of defense from 2007 to ten
we got Baroness Neville Jones former
minister for security and
counterterrorism also have us the Rafik
chief executive of the Quilliam
foundation a counter extremism
organization now before we get their
thoughts let's first hear from a British
is fighter who's now in a Syrian jail
and desperate to come home and face
punishment he spoke to our special
correspondent Alex Crawford from a
secret location in northern Syria Shaban
Suliman story by his own admission is
hard to believe I take responsibility I
was with Isis I was with the terrorist
organization I mean well I mean I didn't
kill anyone I hope I didn't oppress
anyone I mean I mean I did have a
question coffin military uniform but I
didn't I didn't hit anyone I didn't
oppress anyone if you understand I mean
I was there in with military police
perimeter police like I said I was in
the office he joined up with is at the
height of their fortune in 2015 after
the extremists had declared a Caliphate
stretching across Syria and Iraq
the motivation Shabazz insists was to
help the Syrian people rebelling against
President Bashar al-assad and under
constant attack by the regime hey wasn't
about beheading at the beginning wasn't
about beheading or killing it was there
to defend the Syrian state I honestly I
came here for that first but Isis
changed but he was quickly put into
training and is propaganda videos depict
that as intense the grammar school boy
from Buckinghamshire soon found himself
on the frontline of the battle on the
Iraqi border I didn't participate about
that I was spoken English so I was like
reinforcements I was basically
reinforcements well I told the battle in
front of me you are essentially selling
yourselves not to same you selling
yourselves to Isis as is collapsed amid
fierce fighting in Rattler and Dara's or
he fled towards the Turkish border
honestly no I mean terrorists when you
think of terrorists you think someone
you know with their masks and you know
with a sword do you know / hitting
people and terrorizing people well
honestly I was no I mean I was just
relaxed hiding in Raqqa with Syrian
civilians Italy be friends there from
Italy
playing PlayStation or to go around and
bite rights and normal life
no more like this in Isis territory
story interview let's get quick reaction
from our panel just to what we've heard
some what we've heard they're poorly
Neville Jones I mean if you didn't know
what he'd done you think it was a kind
of plausible intelligent young man
should we take him at face value I want
to hear a lot more from him and about
him the much longer interview to come to
any any conclusion that I was remotely
confident about there before I decided
you know we're broadly speaking in a
spectrum of of innocent and naive
through two extremely cunning and
and well well-educated and capable then
of telling another story okay all of
those things are possible Quick Reaction
that's good so talk to him or
interrogate him or more of course
Chapman you know question flowing on
from that is where would you do that
keep him where he is at arm's length or
let him come back why you have a range
of options you can exclude him from
coming back into the temporary
provisions order so you can control how
he comes back and deal with him as he
comes back so he doesn't have a free
rein just to come back on his own terms
so that can be controlled by some of the
legislative processes as to what he did
if he was in combat uniform and he had
an ak-47 and he was trained that looks
to me like a bit of a soldier and
therefore he looks culpable to me but
you'll also know by his feed that he did
for example his media profile what he
said over the period so there's lots of
evidence-based analysis which will give
you the ability to sift through yeah
you're nodding along that Hamas Rafiq I
mean we saw how a debt well the
so-called Caliphate seemed to exist how
adept this organization was a
communication particularly through
social media could this be part of that
spin oh absolutely I think well the
couple of things say first of all nobody
who joined Isis believes that they were
a terrorist they believed they were part
of God's gang give you like they
believed everybody else is a terrorist
so and secondly I think by the very fact
that he he said he didn't oppress
anybody he was part of the military
police there he was actually oppressing
people but the moment he put he joined
them and put on the uniform but but the
point you made is very interesting Isis
were very they handled the media very
very well in terms of getting their
messages at they spun their messages
very very well and I think one of the
lessons that we need to learn is that by
knowing that they spin media and are
able to spin media very well we need to
examine whether they're spinning now
whether this person is part of that
spinning back to get back into the
country well I think they're hear a lot
of agreement there but I'm gonna hold
that thought because we were lucky
enough to have Alex Crawford on the line
now we can see us she joins us now from
Istanbul and Alex I want to hear from
you because you looked him in the eye
and you asked in the tough questions did
you believe
while I was able to speak to him for one
hour 40 minutes we didn't know how long
we were going to get with him because he
was under guard with the Free Syrian
Army so I had no idea whether I had five
minutes or anything longer and I just
talked to him for every single second
that I had with him and I found him in
fact our whole team found him extremely
evasive he was very vague in lots of
areas concerning dates times and places
even cities as to where he was at
certain points and yet very specific
about playing Playstations even telling
me the games that he was playing on the
PlayStation because his story was that a
lot of the time use and the office
playing games on his laptop or hiding
away I thought he was extremely vague
about his period in prison he said he'd
spent among a month in jail and he
specifically mentioned underneath the
prison of Raqqa Stadium which of course
had been blazoned across every single TV
news channel and internet outlet about a
week or so earlier and when I mentioned
other British prisoners who our sky team
had found in that prison he suddenly
looked very nervous and very shocked and
I asked him if he'd seen them he didn't
he had no recollection of anyone else
who was in that prison and yet he'd been
there for a month I'd spoken to many
civilians who came out of Raqqa or
indeed were thrown into prison and they
remember every single detail I spoke to
a year CIDI sex slave who'd been under
Isis control for three years and she
remembered every single name of all the
men who raped her
I think if these are traumatic events
you remember the detail in finite amount
of detail so he was very evasive on many
areas even to the point of when he
actually left racket he couldn't
remember the date or even the month he
kept on referring to it was around
Danny was at the start of the campaign
very very Annie constantly whenever I
was asking him specific detail he would
say a number of times he'd say I know it
sounds unbelievable and it's up to you
whether you believe me or not
and on occasion at least twice he said
I'm not used to talking English so let
me just think about the words and I felt
he was playing for time to try and
gather his information number the time
he seemed quite well rehearsed in when
he was doing his answers now even if we
believe what's his story
even if everything he says is true and
he was disillusioned from almost as soon
as he arrived there and spent his time
trying to get out he has by his own
admission been witnessed to some very
very traumatic events he talked about
crucifixions he talked about bodies
being hung around LaRocca circle he's
also been in the center of one of the
most brutal regimes in modern day
history so he is a very different man at
age 22 to 3 years earlier when he was
just about to go and study international
relations at Keele University so even if
everything he says is true and he does
want to come back and he says he loves
Britain he is a very very different
person today ok Alex thanks for that and
congratulations on an extraordinary
piece of journalism we use the sky data
poll to ask if the public thinks that
are or are not any circumstances in
which Britons who travel to join Islamic
state should be allowed to return to the
UK without being prosecuted here are the
results are not came in at 70 percent
are at 21% don't know 9 percent well let
me go to you chip on that because I
asked you know when it came to one
individual the individual we've been
discussing where the discussion should
take place according to our poll
basically people think they shouldn't be
allowed back in the first place well
yeah I'd accept that that's what they'd
say because of course with the terrorist
attacks we've had in the UK this year
the dread hazard of terrorism is very
high at the moment and of course it's
fear of terrorism which really upsets
people and makes them reticent about the
chaps coming back now of course you
can't make them stateless so they've got
to go somewhere and you can only
prosecute at the national level not
internationally so they could be
prosecuted in Turkey or wherever they
end up but I think we have to realise
that those who are the religious zealots
are probably not going to come back
they're either going to die in place or
go to a new theatre of jihad so it's the
middle branch you will probably have to
deal with and even more so than that the
real difficult issue of potentially 50
children of out there from British
mothers and how do we deal with that
then is there a humanitarian side to
this are the British public being too
harsh no I mean I can fully understand
the figures seventy percent saying that
he shouldn't be allowed back if we do
allow them back and I think there are a
number of things before we have to allow
them back first of all the crimes
they've committed have been committed in
Iraq and therefore the Iraqi government
should have first chance of prosecuting
them if they if they if they want to or
Turkey or other places but if we do have
to allow some of them back we can't make
them stateless then we have to prosecute
them I think we don't have the death
penalty in this country so I don't think
it's a matter of the result of a
judicial process
I think whatever you think about the
merits of his remark I think it's
unrealistic suppose that actually they
are all going to be killed in battle
some of them will disperse roaming other
parts of the world because that seems to
be what's happening with the with these
drone strikes they're taking place in so
many many areas well I have some
reservations about that I have to say I
mean I think you know when you're in
there when it's when it's a clear
battlefield that's one thing I think
chasing people around the world with
drones as I'm not not so happy about
that
but they do think I do think that and
some of them are getting to return I
suspect it'll be a minority because I
think the others will not like they want
to come back because they know perfectly
well what awaits them when they come
back I agree with what Harris has just
said you know you take them through a
process I think the majority of them are
probably going to be culpable
on that note I'm afraid we must end it
thank you all very much indeed Baroness
Neville Jones chip Chapman Halas Rafiq
very good to get your thoughts thank you
very much indeed for adding them to the
and you're watching a Sky News special
program justice for jihadis coming up
we'll find out if current laws are
enough to deal with Britain's returning
is fighters and get the view of a former
Guantanamo Bay detainee stay with us
welcome back to the Sky News special
program justice for jihad ease now
there's disagreement about the threat
posed by returning foreign fighters with
some experts and politicians arguing for
tougher legislation while others hold
the belief that those that do come back
to Britain may not want to attack their
home country and their experiences could
actually be used for counterterrorism
efforts so what should happen to them
when they get back in to the United
Kingdom should they go to prison or be
rehabilitated and D radicalized well
with me now is marzan Berg a former
detainee of course at Guantanamo Bay now
a director of the advocacy group cage
Osman Ahmed is the executive director of
Rights Watch UK is also an international
lawyer and a Raffaello pantucci is
director of international security
studies at RUSI that is the Royal United
Services Institute welcome to you all
but first of all kick off our debate I
want to throw into it a Sky News data
poll we asked if the maximum penalty
penalty for being a member of Islamic
state without committing any other crime
it's 10 years in prison we asked was it
much too harsh or at the other extreme
not harsh enough well the polling
results showed that over half of those
that took part fifty one percent thought
that the punishment is not strong enough
with only 11 percent saying it was too
harsh
well now let's start off then with our
panel and see what they make of it yes I
mean do you agree with that poll 10
years not harsh enough I think one of
the significant issues and challenges
for the government is not about
potentially how harsh the sentences will
be or not be
it's about potentially the challenges
that they face around prosecuting people
when they return and the difficulties in
terms of intelligence and evidence that
can be used in
korte so I think the real question is
how the government are actually dealing
wholesale with the return of foreign
fighters and there have been
particularly I think alarming and
problematic statements by ministers and
by government officials such as Rory
Stewart who have essentially said that
anyone who is in Syria who's a British
citizen who's supportive of ISIL will be
killed and that's one of our strategies
to ensure that the foreign fighters
don't return that doesn't take account
of and in a sense is not obviously
nuanced enough to take account of and
it's a transparent of the fact that one
that the United Kingdom is only legally
able to target those people were
actively participating in hostilities
not everybody and it obviously very
difficult and I think the other thing to
bear in mind as well is that there is a
multiplicity of tools that the
government needs to consider and use
with respect to this and one of them
obviously is prosecution and the an
issue will be on sentences but the other
issue is about rehabilitated you've
you've opened that front for me Mars in
bed but first of all just back to that
poll ten years too harsh you know
there's a few questions here and first
of all we've been saying Syria and there
are there's no evidence to show exactly
the numbers of Isis fighters there are
many people who've gone out to fight
four different organizations who British
government in one way or the other at
least up until 2014 was supporting with
non-lethal aid so other groups are we
talking about all of them and we just
talked about Isis we have to be very
specific about this because the threat
at least we can all agree on it does
come from Isis but does it come from all
foreign fighters the I would beg to say
that that's not the case and okay but if
that were if that were defined and
assessed and and monitored and
investigated the the fighter returns to
the United Kingdom should they in almost
all cases be prosecuted in each case I
think it has to be looked upon its own
merits as as the court would do
regardless they wouldn't be a blanket
prosecution of every single person I
know for a fact many people have
returned to the United Kingdom who
haven't been prosecuted but and it's an
intelligence decision made by the police
and so forth there's a bigger question
to be asked and that is we've launched
war after war had 14 pieces of
anti-terror legislation to stop
terrorism in this country
including the prevent program which is
now in our schools and the threat has
only got worse and worse we have more
anti-terror legislation that at this
point in time than we did at the height
of the IRA campaign when 3,000 people
want to get on sir in a moment I just
want to get her a file or plan to cheese
view on the sentencing I mean should it
even come to sentencing
I mean I think it does another case by
case basis I think people who have
gotten to join a proscribed terrorist
organization like Isis which has had an
avowed intent of trying to launch
attacks against this country and
repeatedly stated that they do have to
be consequences that however do can we
make a blanket statement about the same
level of sentencing for every single
case clearly not some people have done
some atrocious acts and should be
prosecuted for those others will have
done a smaller much well let's throw
into this discussion the UK independent
reviewer of terrorism legislation he is
of course as you all know max Hill and
this is his view on it and I think many
of you chiming along with this
legislating he says in the name of
terrorism when the targeted activity is
not actually terrorism would be quite
wrong we do not and should not
criminalize thought without action or
preparation for action and that my son
Beck seems to be what you were saying
that we need a more nuanced approach and
there there are other ways and perhaps
these other ways actually might work
better well what we know for a fact is
our anti-terror legislation over the
past you know 14 15 years it simply
hasn't worked terrorist attacks keep
becoming even more bold than before
despite all of the powers our security
services have a colleague of mine
Mohammed Rabbani recently was prosecuted
and convicted for refusing to forgive
his password at an airport which he was
holding for on a on an electronic device
for testimony given to him by a torture
survivor so the reason why he was
prosecuted was because he didn't give
his his password and there was no
suspicion in his case at all so he was
stopped without any suspicion which is a
law we have from 2000 and the day's
schedule said okay so plenty and in some
some some views there are too much
terrorism legislation but I just want to
focus in on those those people who have
been overseas taking up on
in some way shape or form with enemies
of the United Kingdom and Osman Ahmed
you were getting on to this issue we've
discussed imprisonment in nearly all
cases could some of the returnees be
actually used as a tool in anti
radicalization programs well there are
certainly people who have expertise in
this area that suggests that that
actually it's very useful in terms of
being able to understand and provide
intelligence and expertise and knowledge
that would be very important in
influential and being able to deal with
the threat I think for me as well just
following on from what mazaa was saying
was that it's really important to
consider the efficacy and the
implications of any laws and policies
that we adopt in this space do you think
they I mean in some cases they can make
it worse potentially make it worse
absolutely and it's not something that
I've only said it's something for
example of the UN Security Council's
Committee on counterterrorism as
actually so much helped me to be saying
it and Mex who was echoed the same
statement and I want to bring into this
somebody who has it admitted fighting
for Islamic state he spoke he may have
seen it a bit earlier to our special
correspondent Alex Crawford Shabazz
Sulaiman and this is his view on what
he's done and what he would do if he
returned and I regret it mainly for my
family regrets mainly that I put my
family through it but definitely put my
family through a lot I was shaken redeem
myself for that
well Raphael upon to cheer me that could
be a powerful message could it not if he
sending if you send him around the
schools and talk to community groups or
would he be too much of a danger I mean
I think the difficulty is that we've
seen with other examples of people who
have supposedly rejected these ideas and
using them as sort of vehicles to try to
persuade others it doesn't always
necessarily work as you would expect it
to in some cases it has succeeded but in
other cases it has not I think in this
particular case of this individual I
don't know the full details of when he
went out there what exactly he was doing
is he being fully open at this point
about what he put
Vater did well if he is and he comes
back and faces the consequences of the
legal system either where he is now or
where he is I mean the questions there
and let's not talk about one individual
but some so you've you form a view that
you know the may or may not be a danger
if they're a danger you lock them up now
we know what's going on in our prisons
huge amounts of radicalization taking
place there with relatively low-level
criminals mixing with the hardened would
be charrisse and whoops it's a
University of Terror it's a very
difficult question how to manage this
within a prison context now the
approaches being taken at the moment is
try to isolate the individuals who are
who are who advocated radical ideas and
tried to keep them apart from the
general prison population but it's not
totally clear that that's actually going
to be able to manage the problem or
rather just concentrate in a specific
place but at least if you may be able to
isolate them you can work on them on an
individual basis to try to steer them
off these ideas okay welcome back we've
got to get a last thought here I mean if
we do go along with that poll and lock a
lot of people up and more or less throw
away the key could that lead to bigger
problems further down the line it will
because of Lisa eventually by necessity
two miscarriages of justice at some
point or the other if you've got
somebody who wants to come along and say
just because I was a member of Isis
you're gonna throw the key away and lock
me up and I want to actually help to
reform myself part of the prison issue
is rehabilitation and reform and if not
allowed to do that beforehand if you
don't not given an opportunity to come
out and for example I remember I've been
imprisoned in 2014 for going to Syria
the case against me collapsed I met in
prison several people who had been part
of Isis or been drawn ok must end and
there thank you all very much indeed
Raphael Pucci Mozambique and Yasmin
Ahmed very good to see you all thank you
very much indeed for your thoughts so
foreign fighters once flooded to join us
from many parts of the globe and now is
the territory they once claimed as their
Caliphate is being retaken the challenge
for the UK as well of course as dozens
of other countries is how to
rehabilitate or at least contain these
thousands of indoctrinated deeply
dangerous and damaged young people who
return how that task is handled as we've
heard will determine whether there ever
we'll be true justice for jihad ease